[Music]
my husband made a big donation to his
fraternity 16 years after undergrad only
to break the news to me moments before i
went in for a painful medical procedure
well that just sounds like bad
communication
terrible timing terrible timing bad
communication it's a great joke yeah
like you would see this on like the
office or something right like hey by
the way i gave 10 grand on my ex
fraternity good luck on your surgery yes
that's something michael scott would do
yes it is
well you know um i don't know man i
think
i think with uh kristin here
if you're in a romantic relationship
like there there is a level
or a certain set of boundaries that
you have to agree on and you know it
just sounds like it was maybe bad
planning and bad communication it
doesn't mean that
you know kristin's right and her
husband's wrong or or anything like that
it just means that
there has to be a little bit
better interaction going on between the
the two of them yeah there doesn't have
to be anything but yeah yeah your
husband was inconsiderate in two ways
one had to do with he didn't talk to you
about this
donation beforehand this is something
if it's something that's a large
purchase or a large output of money
talking to your significant other bare
minimum
right
because
you want to be on the same page yeah and
let's say you get great joy out of doing
this don't you want to share that joy
with your spouse yeah
and so you're inconsiderate because
you're also not sharing your joy with
your spouse beforehand because you can
plan it together you can budget it
together
and you can both make a convicted
decision to do this together how
wonderful is that yeah the second way
you were inconsiderate
is
you didn't think about the timing
we get so wrapped up in our own heads
it's hey i'm just doing this thing i'm
going to tell you real quick in fact he
may have been trying to brush it under
the rug since you're going through a
stressful situation right now we're not
going to have time to argue about this
it's just it's totally inconsiderate and
so
being compassionate involves timing as
well
because sometimes if you show up and you
just want to fix someone's problems
that's not compassionate maybe they just
need someone to listen to in that moment
and so the time dictates simply
listening but if someone's going through
a
procedure like this
it just dictates being there with them
and certainly not bombarding them with
purchases or even with new information
right now
i wouldn't even try to have this
conversation let alone bombard them
blindside them
with this
family decision to make a financial
commitment to an institution of course
your wife's going to be upset about this
and she's going to be doubly upset
because she's already upset about this
other thing which
tints whatever other experience you're
talking about about right now even if
this is something that she was going to
be
that kristen was going to be excited
about
yeah if you approach it at the wrong
time it doesn't give her the room the
space
to feel that same joy that you would
otherwise experience during normal times
under regular communication
did you enjoy this standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel one hundred
percent advertisement free